normally around this time of the year
abdul kareem hussein's farm in sudan's
blue now state
near the border with ethiopia has more
fruits but the farmer says the past year
has been different than previous years
and he blames it on changes in the blue
nile river just meters away
we lost the silt we get from the river
every year the river comes from the
european highlands carrying a lot of
silt
is good for our river irrigated farms
because it changes the soil
but the past year has brought less silt
because of the renaissance dam storing
water
and we don't know if we'll get it this
year abdel kareem's farm is one of
hundreds of thousands of acres in the
state
that lie along the banks of the blue
nile and depend on the river for
irrigation
but the ethiopian renaissance dam being
built upstream on one of the two sources
of the river
is raising concerns it's said to be
africa's largest hydroelectric dam upon
completion
and ethiopia says it'll lift more than
half of its population out of poverty
but in downstream sudan farmers fear it
will reduce their productivity
mohammed mustafa's farm lies nearly 500
kilometers down the river
near the sudanese capital khartoum he
says even he has noted changes in the
soil
since the first filling of the ethiopian
renaissance dam
allah the effects the renaissance them
have been bad for us
if there is no silt then there will be
no farming because we need it for the
soil
last year there was very little silt and
so we couldn't farm crops
and where we farmed the crops died
because of soil quality
talks to reach a deal about the filling
and operation of the dam have repeatedly
failed
sudan says information sharing is
critical during this process
sudan's government says nearly 5 million
people suffered the impacts of the first
filling
of the ethiopian renaissance dam that
was completed last year without an
agreement
this year the government says 20 million
people or half the population will be
affected
that includes not only farmers along the
nile but millions of people who rely on
the river for their water supplies
that's because unlike last year when 4.9
billion cubic meters of water was stored
the second filling is expected to store
13.5 billion cubic meters
those who rely on the nile for water are
afraid of shortages
after last year's filling created
problems for some water treatment plants
the renaissance dam's environmental
impact is also yet to be fully revealed
those who rely on the river for other
means of livelihood say changes in the
past year
have affected their trade
we rely on mud silt and water from the
nile to make bricks the most important
is silt because it's what keeps the
materials together
otherwise it's just a block of mud but
silt has reduced since last july
that's meant bricks of lower quality
which we have to sell cheaper
the third phase of filling the
renaissance dam is scheduled to happen
next year
no new rounds of talks have been
announced yet but for many like abdel
karim
the hope is that something is worked out
before the changes to their farms become
irreversible
hiba morgan al jazeera al-bagher sudan
well let's now hear from nada neural
dean he is a professor of soil and water
sciences at cairo university he joins us
now
from there professor i want to focus on
the practicalities of the second filling
now ethiopia is saying it's done
and i recall the first filling went much
more quickly than expected because of
the reigns
how's this one gone
so far the first announcement with ub
away with the second refilling
uh is will be uh 6.9
billion cubic meter and the second
announcement is claimed that ethiopia
try to reach
13.5 billion cubic meter at uh
by the half of next august
but we don't know so far
the real volume of the water
that isubia will feel in the second
refill
because the working in
increased highest of the middle
wall that prevents the uh
river nile stream it is still working
even under heavy rain and under flooding
and the
italian company claimed that they have a
new technique
for uh cementing and uh
for concrete can touring
to uh against uh heavy rain and
against the flooding and thus we are not
sure if the
the total refill of the second refill
will be
6.5 or will be 13.5
okay well so volumes of water in the dam
aside
we know that ethiopia is now saying
there should be no change to the water
level of the blue nile because of the
rains that we've seen
i know there have been some
contradictory reports from sudan about
whether or not there's actually been a
drop in the water levels of the blue now
since this filling began
presumably egypt is also keeping an eye
on things have you noticed
a drop yeah this is a great drop
because the what's the meaning of
reservoir that's mean
ethiopia will restore water more than
they permitted to to a flow of stream of
water
the water discharge of the blue nile
will
decrease sharpie to be only between
50 to 70 million cubic meter a year and
they will restore between 300 up to 400
million cubic meter
uh sorry a day not a year and this is
means ethiopia will give sudan and egypt
only 20 percent
of the amount of water that
they used to to receive in this time
every year and this is make a suddenly
shock
for uh decreasing of water requirement
in sudan by 80 percent
so that's right this is what happened
yes i do want to be
clear sorry because um there's obviously
a huge amount of discrepancy about
the various different opinions about how
much water will continue flowing down
the blue nile
i'm curious since the second filling
began have you noticed a specific drop
in water in the blue nile because the
ethiopians are saying because of the
rains there's been no drop
are you in egypt there noticing a drop
in the water levels
we don't know if the flooding this year
will be high or will be
short we we don't have if we have a
plenty of water or not because
we are in the beginning of the rain
season in ethiopia and
thus the drop of water is it may be
according
to how much ethiopia will store
in this secondary field but but of
course we
the decrease of the the used of the
amount of water that received by egypt
and sudan will decrease by 80 percent
if this is what you asked about right so
clearly
quite a lot of uncertainty still there
about water levels
neural dinner professor of soil and
water sciences at cairo university
thank you for sharing your thoughts and
expertise with us on al jazeera sir
you're welcome